different sets of skills are very
important uh skills in livestock
production or animal husbend is very
important and uh facilitation skill is
important Knowledge Management is
important and teamwork or team building
uh skill is very important and uh
planning is also very important and
documenting lessons is also very
important so somebody who wanted to work
in this Innovation systems perspective
needs to have both technical skills in
his field of specialization and
horizontally he has to have some uh
additional skills social skills and you
learn those from ILY or do you have them
before you come to ILY uh definitely I
learned from
uh by engaging myself in this kind of
project otherwise previously I was in
the University I was a lecturer and all
I posed about was just to have better
knowledge and Technical knowhow on in my
field of specialization as agricultur
Economist now I have to deal with number
of issues which was not uh formally
given in schools or in any
University